il faut stabiliser le financement de nos
services de garde
c'était le 20 février dernier le
gouvernement de pauline marois annonçait
dans son budget qu'il comptait augmenter
les frais de garderie de 7 à 9 dollars
par jour d'ici 2015 avant d'être indexé
les années suivantes
alors qu'en pensent les québécois dans
un autre volet de notre sondage crop
radio canada plus de la moitié d'entre
eux 55% se disent d'accord avec cet os
et les deux tiers 67% serait en faveur
d'une indexation et ses tarifs au pâlir
d'envié bien des parents d'autres
provinces canadiennes où une place en
garderie peut parfois coûter plus de
1000 $ par mois
voyons ce qu'a préparé frédéric arnould
en route pour la garderie familiale
le p'tit ouest baxter la marche va comme
chaque jour chez samira qui accueille
quelques enfants dans un tout petit
appartement
il en coûte entre 900 et 1000 dollars
par mois par enfant
un prix qui n'effraye personne ici j'ai
presque je sais pas quand mais une
dizaine de personnes sur la liste
d'attenté
la garderie de samira ne pourra
accueillir de nouveaux enfants avant fin
il n'y a pas de garderie qui partait
kickoff toutes les droites et une
gardienne qui les frais de garde pour un
enfant âgé de un à trois ans sont en
moyenne de trente deux dollars par jour
au canada
c'est en ontario et en
colombie-britannique qu'ils sont les
plus élevées à 43 et 42 dollar par jour
beaucoup plus donc que les 7 dollars par
jour déboursés par les familles
québécoises dans les faits à vancouver
c'est encore plus cher jusqu'à plus de
60 dollars par jour de quoi faire
réfléchir virginie avec un deuxième
enfant c'est pas comme s'ils avaient un
rabais sur le deuxième la sellette non
non non plein gré
après 1800 1900 ou 2000 $ par mois ses
goûts une grosse hypothèque patricia
raccompagne à la maison et le ca 9 ans
maximilien 6 ans et thomas qui a presque
deux ans patricia n'est pas la maman
mais bien la gardienne des enfants de la
famille cloutier tremblay il reste à la
maison et s'occupe à temps plein du
petit thomas et de ses frères et soeurs
après l'école jusqu'à l'arrivée des
parents coût 200 $ par semaine avec la
nourriture et le logement pour patricia
moins cher que la garderie pour cette
famille de jeunes médecins et on est
déménagé pour des points de vue
professionnel donc c'était pas comme une
question de fin d'été en plus pour la
garde de nos vins une nounou à la maison
ne faisait pas partie des plans de
virginie et derek car il n'y avait pas
de place pour la loger la garderie leur
impose donc des sacrifices et du calcul
dans la tente de l'arrivée de leur
deuxième enfant d'avoir ce que je peux
me permettre
la garderie à temps plein est-ce qu'il
faut que j'ai avec un temps partiel
cheron grayson travail dans cette grande
garderie éducative qui coûte pour chaque
enfant 1200 dollars ces quatorze mille
dollars par an plus cher qu aller à
l'université
un prix prohibitif qui lui a donné une
idée militer pour des garderies à 10
dollars par jour
la province auraient à assumer une
facture de 1 milliard et demi de dollars
qui seraient échelonnées sur plusieurs
années le temps de créer des
infrastructures un investissement pour
assurer un service de qualité
selon elle beaucoup de garderie fonction
donc au noir pour moins cher mais avec
beaucoup plus de risques de négligence
des cas qui ont fait les manchettes ici
lors de tragédie l'investissement de
contribuables serait donc une nécessité
selon
défenseurs des garderies subventionnées
un choix fiscal que les québec a fait
mais qui est jusqu'ici refusée par la
colombie britannique au désespoir des
parents en panne avec moins de taxe sur
les produits et services mais
globalement j'ai tellement catane -
pourtant l'argent au final reste que
l'augmentation des frais de garderie
annoncée dans le dernier budget
québécois de 7 à 8 dollars cet automne
et de 9 $ l'année suivante fait réagir
les parents ici regarde reality check je
dirais que la réaction de l'envi un peu
de lait baxter la marche et les
critiques et tremblay n'envisage pas
pour autant d'heureux déménagé au québec
ils sont pour l'instant toujours prêts à
payer le prix pour vivre ici